also brauchen wir plan b wenn nicht
sogar und plan c und das muss innerhalb
von
1000 oder hundertstelsekunden
entscheiden eigentlich was man macht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
herzlich willkommen zum sport robot dem
sport podcast des österreichischen
bundesheers heute zu gast der zweifache
silber mit einem gewinner bei olympia in
peking
2022 zugführer wolfgang kindl herzlich
willkommen und gleich einmal herzlich
relation zu diesen wahnsinnig tollen
leistungen vielen dank man kann sagen
endlich hat es geklappt
viermal jetzt dabei gewesen und die
ersten zwei olympischen medaillen wie
war das erlebte für dich in peking ja
genau so wie du gesagt hast also ich hab
schon immer wieder erfahrung sammelte
wollte man es wird einmal dabei bei
olympischen spielen und das ist halt
immer wieder eigentlich das highlight
und natürlich was aber den spielen der
forscher das ziel medaille zu holen aber
es hat leider nicht geklappt und hier
war immer wieder weitergearbeitet und um
die eigene haut auf das ziel
hingearbeitet und der kongress erfüllt
und das doppelte also darum so cool war
das auch die die vorgabe vorher kann man
das bei euch im motorsport auch sagen
ich war als hin ich komme damit alle
zurück oder man muss man einfach schauen
wie sich das rennen ergibt es ist auch
ein bisschen anders als im wettkampf bei
euch vater bei olympia vier läufe und
stadt von zwei leuten also kann man sich
das im vorfeld schon so ausrechnen oder
was du wirklich überrascht auch trotz
zielsetzung dass es dann mit zwei
silbermedaillen so gut gelaufen ist
natürlich immer schwierig zu sagen im
vorfeld dahin und tolle medaille
natürlich erstmal setzt als ziel aber es
muss alles zusammenpassen bei uns ist ja
der material faktor sei sehr groß also
es muss wirklich an dem tag oder an den
beiden tagen zurück sagt es geht bei uns
über vier läufe was natürlich schon
große unterschied ist dass schlafmangel
drüber je nachdem wie leicht der
dauerhaft besser oder schlechter und vor
allem er ist
so komplett etwas anders und lässt sich
so nicht planen und natürlich hat mir
davon trainingsfahrten was wir mit
seiner band recht kommt sie überhaupt
natürlich oder gott sei dank das glück
gehabt dass ich mir sehr gutes recht
gefunden habt gleich von anfang an wenn
du eigentlich schon immer bei den besten
und schnellsten dabei ist neu im
training schon und errechnet man sich
natürlich so aus als könnte möglich sein
und man rechnet sich immer ein bisserl
doch wer sein die stärksten konkurrenten
aber ihr vater vor august im training
zum beispiel die deutschen sagen nie
alles also die haben immer noch
irgendetwas im körper auf seinen hin und
ja es hat viele meilen an weitergeben
und im endeffekt war es für mich aber
dann umso überraschender dass sie so
stark vorne mitfahren können im
endeffekt wirklich ganz ganz knapp nur
auf gold und das ist sowas dabei wenn
hatte im vorfeld nicht gedacht und dann
die zweite medaille mit dem team war
eigentlich ähnlich wir haben gewusst
wenn jeder seine leistung bringt dann
kann man sich ja die chance eine
medaille zu holen sagt ja wenn jetzt
wirklich jeder seine topleistung bringt
keine mangold mitfahren sondern im
endeffekt arbeiter ganz knapp und vor
dem herrn man kann es ja im vorfeld
erhoffen aber planen ist immer schwierig
bleiben wir doch ganz kurz vor einer
einzelmedaille im verlauf des rennens
gibt es dann ein moment wo man es gegen
die mitbekommt und singende klick macht
und man weiß jetzt hole ich mir das ding
einfach oder ist da wirklich bis zum
letzten moment noch diese unsicherheit
da weiß ja bei euch auch wirklich so eng
zugeht also da entscheiden ja wirklich
die absolute kleinigkeiten ob man jetzt
ein problem steht oder nicht dazu gibt
es da wirklich ein moment wo man sagt
diese gewissheit ist da ich weiß mit
edelmetall nach hause oder das nicht
jeder vorschlag sagte es geht über vier
läufe das war technisch anspruchsvolle
bahn träumen bringt er sie dahin gebaut
haben und vor wenn man hat wirklich
immer alles passieren kann in einem
jeden lauf und sich als ideal dass sie
super 1 gestartet bin war eigentlich
gleich von anfang an richtig stark dabei
dann war ein bisschen abstand also tritt
viertplatzierten und so weiter und nach
dem ersten tag war schon in einer sehr
guten position und dann habe ich mir
schon gedacht die haben man kann damit
spekulieren aber es muss natürlich vom
zweiten tag dann wieder so weiterlaufen
und dann war der drittel auf eigene
faust beste was er überzeugt habe und
dann war der abstand nach hinten
normalgröße und die sonst niemand
aufgeregt und dann habe ich schon
langsam eigentlich realisiert das kann
jetzt wirklich möglich sein und muss man
sagen ein drittel auf 801 also wurde er
dann unten war vom letzten war
eigentlich die sicherheit da das ist
wirklich drauf habe und da sind wir
holen kann was auf jeden fall auch im
wechselbad der gefühle dass man dadurch
lebt ist das mit den vier läufen ein
vorteil oder nachteil oder hängt das
einfach vom jeweiligen athleten ab ob
man das dann eher positiv besetzt oder
vielleicht das sogar noch einmal
zusätzlich druck aufbaut wenn du gesagt
hast vom dritten lauf was du dann noch
zusätzlich nervös obwohl es eigentlich
im weltcup schon vorbei gewesen wäre
also ist das ein vorteil oder nachteil
das ist immer individuell wie sich jeder
mit dem up findet
sechs familien eher als vorteil wenn das
eigentliche routinierter fahrer über das
alter holt man sich einfach die routine
dann bin ich eigentlich sehr sehr sicher
im schnitt nicht sehr konstant
eigentlich über die ganze saison
grässlich und dann habe ich schon bus
zur über vier live wie sie sich auf dem
ihr vorteil gibt viele der halt wenn es
ein normales weltcup rennen ist aber
vom material um ließ aber über 4 life
muss dazu sagen und dabei im vorfeld
gewusst das ist eine treppe das was man
gehen könne du hast auch in den letzten
jahren international durchgängig
erfolgreich ist sowohl bei
europameisterschaften als auch der
weltmeisterschaft mit einem gemacht ist
europameister geworden auch heuer 2017
bei der heim-weltmeisterschaft was der
doppelweltmeister ist es zum ersten mal
auf olympischem niveau auch geklappt
nachdem der dreimal davon nicht was
glaubst du hast du heuer anders gemacht
als bei den spielen davor sei nicht so
dass du damals nicht schon gut gewesen
bist weil das haben wir da eine medaille
schon bewiesen was ist was hast du heute
anders gemacht wie der vorschlag habe
sich natürlich über die jahre weiter man
hat einfach mehr erfahrung und wir haben
da war ja schon medaillen favoriten da
war es dann gleich mal noch nach der
vierten fünften glaube aber dann fehler
im ersten lauf und dann so schlecht kann
ich eigentlich normalen kleinen staaten
und dann war es von anfang an sich schon
vorbei
und wie sich aber aus dem glanz ich hab
immer wieder tiefen gehabt aber die
letzten drei jahre eigentlich immer
wieder so ein bisschen zu kämpfen gehabt
weil ihr nicht ganz den speed gefunden
habe
in dem material entwicklung eigentlich
investiert das
auf dem setup her wie weiterentwickeln
und habe dadurch das einfach ein
bisschen eingebüßt und genau
dann speziell was das material setup
betrifft habe sich bislang glücksgriff
betroffen und hier hat er das noch
möglich lautet zusätzlich im sommer sehr
hart gearbeitet an mir selber körperlich
es war doch die letztlich auch ein
bisschen manko dass sie am start
bisschen zu langsam war und das habe
aber ja gezielt
ja sagen wir wirklich ausnutzen können
aber dann beiden olympischen spielen
meine top-leistung am start abrufen
können und das gesamtpaket hat einfach
gepasst aber mit schlitten
startleistung material rund um die
betreuung was man mittlerweile haben
mich so genial und ja er war immer
gesagt dass aber nicht nur er selber
erreicht sondern das ist einfach da
steckt soviel arbeit von jedem dahinter
und ja es ist eigentlich eine gemeinsame
mitteile das heißt die medaille
repräsentiert natürlich auch den erfolg
des gesamten teams symbolisch natürlich
die mannschaftsbewerb also die
mannschaftsteile dann noch umso mehr
aber ich muss mal kurz mit etwas was
gibt dir durch den kopf wenn am start
stehst natürlich
vorher die trainings du kennst die
kurven er weiß ganz genau was wie wo
gemacht werden muss aber was gibt dir am
start ich den kopf ja unmittelbar bevor
man eigentlich quasi renault starten
darf seine bei uns dann noch die
technischen kontrollen abbaubar und
wenn es dann losgeht schaut muss auch
meistens am fernsehen dann davon ob
islam markierte waren nochmal durch
nimmt sich noch einmal die eckpunkte
eigentlich außer sie die wichtigsten
lenkt punkte oder oder die bahn
abschnitte wo man immer wieder im
training vielleicht aber fehler capone
oder probleme gehabt und dann ist man
komplett im fokus und und im tunnel
probiert die gedanken mögliche medaille
oder mögliche fehler oder was kann man
falsch machen das problem so gut wie
möglich auszublenden und
konzentriert sich eigentlich komplett
auf sich selber mich das ganz gut
gelungen nämlich sicher die erfahrung
spielt eine große rolle dass man das
rundum so gut wie raus ein zusätzlicher
stressfaktor war vor ort sicher auch die
situation auf ausgelöst durch die
pandemie mit möglichen kantinen und
permanente unsicherheit ob jetzt dann
doch noch irgendwo ein positiver test
auftaucht wie ist es dir damit gegangen
der ob muss man den gewinner aus italien
hat er gleich nach dem buffet haben
keine zähne müssen also schwingt das
auch ein bisschen irgendwie im
hinterkopf mit oder kann man das gut
ausblenden wenn man wirklich oben am
start steht er als direkt am start muss
ausblenden aber man hat uns alle
verfolgt ein gt ganze zeit wo man sie in
china befunden haben es war einfach
jeden tag ein bisschen nervenkitzel
wassertest oder oder bastelt und malt
sich im vorfeld alles dafür tun dass man
so sicher wie möglich schon nach china
rüberkommt und dass man man durch die
hygienemaßnahmen da drüben getroffen und
seien bei maria ist so gut wie sicher
wieder gesagt schon in dominik
fischnaller in italiener hat es
eigentlich am renntag hoffen da hat dann
direkt nach dem rennen eigentlich kriegt
das sei positiv und hat dann in der
team-staffel nimmer starten können und
vor dem hat man dann wieder gesehen wie
schnell es gehen kann zwar seien im
vorfeld schon
gar nicht am rennen teilnehmen hat
trennen um so mehr ist so unmittelbar
mit krieg wie schnell es gehen kann und
ich glaube wir haben sagte anderes sehen
wenn man die sabine schöffmann oder die
marita grammer das
harte arbeit so schnell dann vorbei sein
kann und von dem her war es schon immer
ein bisschen im hinterkopf also ich
stelle mir das wahnsinnig bitter vor wie
wenn das ergebnis vielleicht am tag
vorher schon positiv ist man dann gar
nicht starten darf und man eine medaille
gemacht hätte so wie die berlinische
kollege also sicher vom kopf her gar
nicht einfach das zu verarbeiten und
immer mitzugehen was man schon noch
gemerkt hat im eiskanal war dass du dich
mit einem deutschen kollegen johannes
ludwig hier gleich abgesetzt hat und
überhaupt die deutsche dominanz im
eiskanal über die bewerbe und
disziplinen hinweg wie erklärst du dir
das video das essen ist eigentlich im
kompletten eiskanal sport dass es war im
april seinen gewonnen bis auf den
monobob die damen dann was kalle dann
wobei die bewerber die deutschen vorne
waren bei uns im jahr alle disziplinen
gewonnen wenn es noch knapp vor dem er
sieht man aber dass wir gute arbeit
geleistet haben weil der abstand zu den
deutschen sicher geringer war nicht in
der letzten jahre übernehmen wieder
zurück erinnern wenn der felix loch war
der olympiasieger war nicht in sotschi
da hat damit über sekunden vorsprung
gewonnen und der dritte wurden 4
sekunden hinten und da sieht man dass
wir schon sehr gute arbeit geleistet
haben also in einem im hintergrund im
materialsektor sehr viel weiter
entwickelt worden ist und da bei mir
iwata fragt ob wir haben drei jahre
jetzt wirklich out investiert dass ich
mich weiterentwickelt und im endeffekt
muss man sich an sich selber arbeiten
aber das thema sind dann steckt arbeitet
wirklich sehr sehr gut und ziel ist
natürlich dass man eine deutsche
verlangt setzen in zukunft sprengt oder
die motivation ist auf jeden fall da
dass der
vorsprung schmilzt und dass der gute
arbeit geleistet wird du hast jetzt auch
seine harte arbeit in den letzten jahren
angesprochen die war auch ausgelöst
dadurch dass du verletzungen hattest und
oftmals auch ratlosigkeit über fehlende
form falle immer nach der
weltmeisterschaft 2017
wie hast du dich durch diese phase
hindurch motiviert gab es auch gedanken
jetzt vielleicht sein zu lassen oder war
das dann ein faktor dass du sagst ich
arbeite jetzt noch härter und irgendwann
mal kommt das alles wieder wie von
selbst ich sage es warm ist schon
ausbauen eigentliches war schon immer
wieder natürlich mit der leistungen
bringt den man sich gewünscht oder hofft
dann denken wir mal wieder für was
machen jetzt überhaupt rentiert jetzt
nur also es waren immer wieder
eigentlich gedanken daran das ist
eigentlich wirklich in wolf und weil er
schon irgendwie schon bissl die
sinnfrage gestellt aber vielleicht war
es auch der ansporn dass man noch
ergeben hat um weiter zu kämpfen und
hatte zu arbeiten jemand hat mir immer
schon wieder möglich aussagen gibt man
wirklich immer als haut kämpft muss auch
sagen dass bundesrat männer sei sehr gut
unterstützt das war jetzt immer die
letzten wenn jetzt mittlerweile
dreizehnte jahr dabei also da natürlich
abgesichert und vor dem haus einmal
wieder möglich zusammen aber die saison
ist so super war die möglichkeit dass
sie weitermachen kann und
bin
und den direkt und dann unterstützt
worden und natürlich denkt man über sich
selber nach was was kann ja an mir
selber holen was kann im materialsektor
anders machen und glaube ich bin immer
einfach abhaut arbeiter und dass ich
immer wieder verkauft und durch den
soffin 8 wird ausgezählt und ja wie ihre
forschung sagt happ ist nicht nur irland
sondern es seinem trainer im hintergrund
da
der und beratschlagen und dann
weiterhelfen du hast deine hatte
arbeitet
noch mal angesprochen und gibt es etwas
was du ausgleichen muss man sagt ja auch
das größere sportler vielleicht einen
vorteil haben am start weil die hebel an
das sind weil die grundgeschwindigkeit
vielleicht anders ist muss aber
vielleicht in bestimmten bereichen noch
einmal mehr arbeiten als andere was dann
für dich wieder ein vorteil sein kann ja
also grundsätzlich muss man sagen mit
gardemaß der war eigentlich braucht fürs
rodeln also ich bin grundsätzlich zu
klären aber probiert es so gut wie
möglich zu kompensieren
speziell im kraftbereich
schnelligkeitsbereich dass ihr das
einfach am start über die frequenz
quasi wettmachen kann man bislang nach
der wm haben aber ich glaube jetzt bei
olympia sagt dass es möglich ist dass
man da vorne mit starten kann und wieder
gesagt hat natürlich fällt mir ein
bisschen gewicht das kann man über blei
zusatzgewichte ausgleichen ich hab das
schon hinkriegen eigentlich an mir am
körper zusätzlich man sie aus erzählen
was macht es nicht leichter das heißt du
fährst mit zusatzgewicht auf die darauf
während dem rennen habe ich das jetzt
richtig was ist eigentlich so
individuell angepasste bleibe stetig an
macht dahinter seite von der
oberschenkel und im rückenbereich sind
auch quasi bleiplatten in wechte drin
und durch das kann ich das ein bisschen
ausgleich und man wenn jetzt auch noch
110 kilo wiegt dann hat aber den vorteil
haben dass ist vom reglement her
festgelegt gibt es ein gewisses
reglement wenn ihr 80 viele haupt kann
die zehn kühe ausgleichen also auf 90
kilo
und
simpel erklärt
mal probiert das halt so gut wie möglich
dann an das gesamtgewicht anzupassen
weil man sich einfach keine chance hätte
aber im eiskanal selber haben wir einen
vorteil weil ich lerne bin durch das
bessere aerodynamik und da kommt auch
die lenkung ins spiel ich meine wenn man
so fragt wie man sich ein rudel
vorstellt dann ist das wahrscheinlich
ganz ganz anders als das was ihr fahrt
das ist nämlich hightech geräte wie
lenkt man so eine rote und im eiskanal
vor allem jetzt in peking hat sich
gezeigt hat ja keiner geschafft
eigentlich dem kanal wirklich fehlerfrei
zu schaffen das heißt war schon
anspruchsvoll wie schafft man es da vor
allem in den geschwindigkeiten die lenk
und gut zu machen
simpler vielleicht ist es so ähnlich wie
bei normalen naturbahnrodler sowie es
jedermann kennt weil man von dir hören
können mit dem fuß drauf drückt noch
jetzt in die richtung also wenn ihr mit
rechts drücken oder fahren wir nach
links das ist ähnlich bizarr zusätzlich
bei uns nur die lenkung über die
komplette achse das heißt man macht
eigentlich immer die lenkbewegungen über
den ganzen körper dass man mit der
schulter mit geld zusätzlich auf der
seite nur begriffe wo man sich halt da
kann man ganz leicht lenken werbung
machen und ja ganz wie sie erklärt
müssen wir schauen dass man in der
ideallinie bleiben das heißt es gibt in
der kufa druckpunkte an denen man lenken
muss wenn man das nicht schafft und
findet man zu weiter an die obere
begrenzung und super freuen kann man es
immer in einem kreisel da sieht man wenn
jetzt andere es nicht schafft doch dann
vor der portale wellenform durch und da
muss man gegen die
fliehkraft und gegen die lenk punkte
eigentlich arbeiten und so den schlitten
inhalt auf spur halten ich stelle mir
das auch wahnsinnig schwer vor wenn man
die ersten zwei drei kurven vielleicht
gute schafft und dann ein fehler
passiert oder man das nicht gut macht
dann muss man ja immer wandern eine
strategie bereit gelegt haben wie man
jetzt weiter fallen sondern muss
wahrscheinlich die kurven führen anders
angehen weil man eine andere
ausgangssituation hat wie schafft man es
sich auf diese situationen vorzubereiten
und dann wirklich die richtige strategie
zu haben um den vorsprung dann doch
keiner werden zu lassen die geht das ja
ist also grundsätzlich gilt es gibt bei
ideal spur es gibt davon die antworten
in die kurve eigentlich immer quasi
ideallinie belegt ist
aber im kopf war die alternativen haben
jetzt einmal die einfach nicht so gut
passt man muss ich wissen was mache dann
also braucht immer ein plan b wenn nicht
sogar und plan c und das muss innerhalb
von
1000 oder 100 sekunden entscheiden
eigentlich was was man macht und von der
mär vom bauern die erfahrung sicher
zugute umso öfter mal vor bankwesen ist
umso mehr fühlt man sich wohl und weiß
man was man in jedem fall tun muß so wie
du es gesagt hat wenn jetzt irgendwo im
oberen bereich einen fehler haben wir
immer davon wie stark der fehler ist
dann war scheint es ist vorbei
oder man denkt sich ja vielleicht hat es
nicht so viel ausgemacht kein war auf
der vor und sägt an einem tag eines war
technik so wenn man es leiser kleine
rutsche hat oder so dann kann man jetzt
schon nur aus merzen aber muss man
wissen was man zu tun hat aber wenn wir
als verband in berührung hat im oberen
bereich vor allem dann wahrscheinlich
das 1 1 verloren und das weiß man auch
in dem moment also weiß man wirklich so
das war es jetzt eigentlich und/oder
fährt man dann trotzdem noch irgendwie
von prozent und versucht alles noch zu
geben weil er weiß ja was den
konkurrenten noch passiert habe ich
bestimmt dass trotzdem metall wahnsinnig
herausforderung man sich wenn man es
wirklich einen groben fehler eingebaut
hat einen text wo sich so wieder
vorgehabt sich hat vielleicht nicht so
viel ausgemacht aber und du musst dann
trotzdem 100 prozent geben weil wenn
dann alles wegwerfen kann sein dass noch
sturz passiert oder oder dummer fehler
oder zwei kann man grundsätzlich
passiert das ja im training einmal
wieder mal was was auf uns zukommt und
yamada wir bei olympique senkt das hat
speziell im unteren teil hat sich mal
wieder stürze geben aber damals lehnte
gleich oder bei gleicher arbeit wo die
fehler so viel ausmachen wo aber dann
ist einen vielleicht noch nicht ganz
vorbei ist will sollte vielleicht drei
vier zehntel kostet und du kannst du
dann urlaub sowie arbeiten im speziellen
wenn es im oberen teil ist
ja verliert man vor den punkt da muss
ich eben normal aufbauen muss das jetzt
auch öfter herausgestrichen dass die
erfahrung so wichtig ist dass man weiß
jemand reagiert in verschiedenen
situationen welches welche rolle spielt
das alter bei euch im rodeln
grundsätzlich ist es so bis ins höhere
alter möglich macht das vorhergesehen
und markus brock glaube hat mit 37 grad
tagsüber hat mit über 40 nach vorne oder
armin zöggeler so die ganz großen vom in
dem sport
im hohen alter annaburg wissen
vielleicht einmal durch die erfahrung
andererseits mag ich das jetzt
mittlerweile ja schon mit 33 dass der
körper erholung braucht mehr pausen man
muss auch anders trainieren
vielleicht dann immer ganz so viel
trainingsfahrten fahren weil das im
körper doch einiges abverlangt und ja
durch stelle der vorstand gesprochen
aber immer wieder verletzungen gehabt
speziell im nackenbereich und
dadurch natürlich das rodeln nicht ganz
ideal weil wir halt den schlägen vom von
den unebenheiten meister ausgesetzt ist
eben den fliehkräften und vor dem er
merkt man schon über die jahre das es im
korb einiges abverlangt aber
grundsätzlich wenn man fit ist und
momentan fühle mir immer gut trotz dem
alter dann glaube ich schon dass noch
einiges oder einige jahre noch möglich
sein also einige olympische spiele auf
jeden fall noch möglich einige nach
eigener wahl
bislang ausblicke und das auf jeden fall
dass jetzt die kräfte angesprochen wie
kann man sich das vorstellen welche
kräfte wirken darauf den körper wie
fühlt sich das an das ist für uns
wahrscheinlich mit nichts vergleichbar
wenn man da wirklich so direkt in der
kurve liegt und die kräfte spürt und ja
vom prinzip wenn man mit einem schnellen
auto fan ist und mal was wir meinen das
gas voll eingedruckten der struktur
ungefähr soll ich das nur im liegen und
smart an nichts was hinter den kopfball
vom autor stellt dann hinten an wir
müssen den kopf nach vorne anfängt vor
weil das geld dann aber bis zu einem
gewissen maße und das ist eigentlich das
was am schwierigsten ist wenn es
wirklich wo auf kurzer strecke viel
fliegauf daherkommt dann kann es schon
mal sein dass der kopf so hinten darüber
ist und man absolut gar nix musik tja so
kann man sich das vorstellen und der
ganze körper in die in die schule rein
passt also
wahnsinnige körperliche leistung die ihr
daher bringt im kopf gibt es auch schon
paradox das heißt meine kollegen mit
behinderung können
mit dem eiskanal den den sport erleben
ist das überhaupt möglich dass ich zwar
schon als einarmiger rodel weil das von
der lenkung normal wären ja also das
kannte man vorstellen
gibt es aber bei uns einfach
niemand ob ich glaube ich habe bislang
einfacher
rein vom vor dem dass man das ziel
finden und das ziel sieht sag ich mal so
weit also es worden ist so vom
technischen anspruch sicher die
schwierigste sportart im eiskanal das
sieht man aber die kinder schon die
müssen ganz unten anfangen weil sie
einfach vorbei probleme haben und dann
eben nicht ins ziel kamen oder mit
schmerzen und wenn man es so sieht das
caledon die keinen klammer von relativ
weiter umfahren apropos später aber ist
für quereinsteiger sozusagen möglich es
gibt ja viele dem was die ausbildung
quasi als rodler genießen und dann im
bobsport übergeben hat es in deutschland
noch immer wieder geben der dann als
erfolgreich waren wie gesagt vielleicht
waren wir
mal ein paar nudeln war es für dich
nimmt immer auch ein doppelsitze zu
fahren weil jetzt gesagt dass das auch
interdisziplinäre wechsel geben kann ja
bei uns gesagt so dass man sich quasi im
juniorenalter entscheiden muss ob einzel
oder doppel meistens wenn man sich das
doppel entscheidend vorn bis zum ende
vor dem juniorenalter beides ist aber
dann immer möglich muss ich eigentlich
spezialisieren es gibt ganz wenige die
das versucht haben es gibt ein
amerikaner der hat symbolisch zu plänen
probiert ich habe das problem dass er
sich einfach das ist zu komplex weil du
musst alle disziplinen trainieren und
das funktioniert dann wenn man also es
gibt keinen der wirklich das erfolgreich
absolvieren kann und von mir war es
nochmal kurz der thema bin damals mit
dem fisch thermal ich habe mal probiert
den fischer brüder waren ja meine
teamkollegen pia und da haben aber nach
der kleinwagenspezialist
und am ring in österreich das kann man
immer wieder gute doppel nach das ist
klar wir funktioniert ganz gut die
arbeit es werde immer gut entschieden
zweite röhre geschaut im verband wo
braucht man die kräfte und das werfen
dem drehen und so ein bisserl
entschieden wenn jetzt zwar zum beispiel
kurz sammeln basteln und sagen sie jetzt
mal doppel probieren und somit bleibt
noch ein paar monzel das heißt da da
schaut man natürlich dass man effektiv
die leute einsetzt auch nach ihren
fähigkeiten und talenten das ändert sich
jetzt für dich für deine weiteren
personen die jetzt dann bevorstehen als
doppelter olympiamedaillengewinner oder
alles gleich für dich mal gleich
natürlich besonders dass laggenbeck es
war hart aber dieses ziel glaube ich von
mir und olympia medaille schon nochmal
um einiges größer wird der forschung
sagt ihr habt wirklich so sehr sehr viel
wohnen sehr sehr viele medaillen bei
großereignissen gewonnen aber olympia
medaille hat man noch fahrt und vor dem
er kann jetzt schon sagen dass
komplettiert vielleicht mal bisherige
karriere bisserl aber grundsätzlich
nicht viel ändern man über die letzten
jahre immer gewusst das ist drauf hab
nur das olympia edelmetall hat nur kalt
und ja vor dem herr
auf der liste hackl mehr und vor allem
darf stand war nicht so groß dass in
vier jahren wird vielleicht die nächste
medaille abgehakt herzlichen dank auf
jeden fall für den besucher alles gute
und gratuliere dir nochmal danke das war
von unserer sportart danke dass ihr mit
dabei wird und bis zum nächsten mal
[Applaus]